elle a été peint khemisti qu'elle est
maman et hier soir elle est devenue
terrassiers la chanteuse berlinoise nina
gkn a détruit une copie une copie du mur
de berlin reconstituer devant l'espace
européen de paris témoin de la scène
michel reinette
happening coloré hier soir du côté de la
place clichy une faune singulière des
centaines de personnes s'étaient
rassemblées devant l'espace européen
dont l'entrée était interdite par un mur
symbolique mais par les meilleurs
graffiteurs de la place vers l'est
étaient dans tous les esprits et l'on
attendait mina again and again confié
par l'association ti follis qui voulait
lui faire la fête
la commune de paris est toujours vivant
dit elle détruire le mur est un acte de
liberté porteur d'espoir pour l'europe
et le reste du monde
nous serons le monde la vie sur la
planète père et nous retournerons à la
spiritualité à l'hommiste et à l'amour
et à la paix des programmes
pour résistantes pour être cassé à la
hache on a employé les grands moyens
pour éclater le mur en béton cellulaire
avant que la foule ne s'en donne à coeur
joie de le piétiner
et chacun avait droit à son morceau
choisi
pendant ce temps la vedette qui a vécu
une partie de sa vie en rda se préparait
en compagnie de ses amis les alternatifs
français anglais et allemand a lancé une
vente aux enchères au bénéfice des
artistes de la rue
la hache de guerre deviendra elle juste
un souvenir